hallo herzlich willkommen zur sallys
welt ich möchte heute einen richtig
leckeren leichten salat machen jetzt
passend zum sommer er eben auch ein
sommerlicher salat und ich werde dann
auch später richtig hübsch anrichten
das zeige ich euch dann noch und zwar
ist es ein sommerlicher couscous salat
erinnert ein bisschen an kabul das ist
so ein libanesischer salat aber ich
mache ihnen nicht so also das ist kein
tabu oder so sondern einfach ein
sommerlicher sally couscous salat den
ich mir vorhin kommt ausgedacht habe
weil ich heute eben was sättigendes zwar
möchte aber nicht so schweres und
deswegen finde ich so salate mit so ein
bisschen couscous immer ganz lecker ich
zeige euch jetzt einfach mal kurz die
zutaten
ich habe hier 200 gramm couscous sag ich
euch gleich noch was dazu eine zitrone
eine halbe gurke drei frühlingszwiebeln
zwei tomaten eine rote paprika so eine
handvoll rucola das sind so etwa 50 bis
80 gramm dann etwas olivenöl salz und
pfeffer und später gehe ich noch auf die
terrasse und hole nur ein paar frische
kräuter wie minze petersilie und so
weiter kommt man einfach was alles da
ist
ich habe jetzt hier schon mal wasser
aufgekocht ich koche kurz noch mal ganz
schnell auf
und jetzt gebe ich den couscous in glas
schälchen mit decke und da kommen jetzt
etwa 600 milliliter wasser mit rhein
kreises und es muss dann einfach mal
etwas durchziehen so etwa eine
viertelstunde dauert es man muss es
nicht auf kuchen sondern es geht einfach
so und couscous ist wird aus grease
gewonnen entweder aus weizen hirse oder
gerste und es sind einfach so kleine
kügelchen etwas anderes als normaler
krise etwas größer grobkörniger und eben
große kügelchen und das lassen wir jetzt
ganz kurz stehen und wenn es dann
gequollen ist dann fange ich erst mit
dem gemüse an
denn dann wird es auch schon ein
bisschen kühl in der zeit ich wohne
jetzt in der zwischenzeit schon meine
kräuter und zwar nehme ich jetzt
petersilie mit und etwas frische minze
und es hier sieht gerade aus wie so ein
bild kräutergarten aber ich muss dir mal
demnächst sauber
jetzt habe ich auch hier meine frischen
kräuter und jetzt können wir den salat
feststellen
diese für mich richtig schön gequollen
müsst ihr zuerst mal einfach diesen
couscous und bisschen auflockern mit dem
löffel oder mit einer gabel auch schon
ein bisschen abgekühlt
dann schneide ich jetzt das ganze gemüse
erst mal klein an der gurke lasse ich
die schale daran dass ich auch eine bio
gurke und die schneide ich jetzt alle in
würfel
ich mache das jetzt hier kurz dem
alligator deswegen schneide ich mir das
kurz in scheiben
die kann ich mir dann da drauf legen und
dann einmal durchschneiden
das gemüse ist jetzt klein als nächstes
nämlich die zitrone da presse ich den
saft aus um mir die vorher so ein
bisschen massiert sag jetzt mal kommt
auch der saft vielleicht daraus den gebe
ich jetzt auch mit dazu
und jetzt werden auch die kräuter
schönen fein gehackt
und wenn ihr da jetzt nicht so viel
petersilie nehmen wollt könnt auch
bisher weniger nehmen
aber ich mag petersilie in salaten total
gerne zumindest in sowohl die oder
couscous salaten und frische minze find
ich könnte auch unbedingt mit rein denn
die bringt da einfach diese frische mit
rein und dann wird eben erst so richtig
sommerlich die zöpfe ich jetzt aber von
dem stil ab oder reißt einfach runde
miller kommt jetzt hier auch noch mit
rein jetzt spüre ich das ganze erst mal
schön durch habe ich ja den couscous
drin das gemüse und den zitronensaft und
ich finde auch allein schon diese farben
sind total schön und machen wir das
sommerlich mit den grünen und dem rot
und vor allem müsste deshalb erst mal
nachmachen und dann dran riechen also
mache ich das schon bei der zubereitung
diesem insel mit der petersilie riecht
doch total orientalisch finde ich hab'
ich geklettert und ich find's super aus
es gebe ich hier noch etwa vier
esslöffel olivenöl mit 34 will noch
sieben sei könne auch sieben sein dann
noch etwas salz und pfeffer was kommt
dabei raus
pfeffer pfeffer finde ich immer frisch
gemahlen ganz gut weil das so das aroma
schön noch hat vor allem kann man sich
ja dann die körner einstellen und was
jeden fein gerieben möchte oder eher
grob und ich hab's meist eher so mittel
grob also mir macht das nichts aus wenn
ich sowieso pfeffer drauf weiß
jetzt wäre der salat eigentlich schon
fertig und wenn ihr aber möchte so wie
ich könnte jetzt gern noch ein bisschen
rucola mit rein geben also muratow nicht
vermögen total gern rucola den schneide
jetzt auch gar nicht klein sondern gibt
ihnen einfach so bisschen klein gezupfte
meter zu hoch oder hat also einen
bitteren geschmack und ich achte immer
darauf dass sich bio rucola kaufe allein
schon wegen schadstoffen und so weiter
wegen dem dünger der luft eingesetzt
wird und ich mag aber diesen bitteren
geschmack richtig toller salat also das
mache ich morgen auch ganz oft rucola
salat mit balsamico dressing und mit
etwas pinienkernen angeröstet mit
parmesankäse total lecker so den salat
lasse ich jetzt ganz kurz durchziehen so
etwa zehn minuten räume hier in der
zwischenzeit auch dann zeige ich mich in
servieren
also ich räume inzwischen zeigen ich
habe jetzt in salaten nochmal
abgeschmeckten zitronensaft salz und
pfeffer das war ein bisschen zu wenig
aber da müsste einfach nach eigenem
geschmack abschmecken
ich mache jetzt dem rat man ständchen
zum probieren
und ich will den rest jetzt hier ab denn
wir nehmen das jetzt gleich noch mit auf
eine feier und wenn ihr das zum beispiel
in so kleinen bläschen oder so kleine
sträßchen fühlt kann man auch immer jede
fraktion abfüllen und dann kann sich
jeder so ein gläschen nehmen und es
einfach so essen
ich finds echt praktisch wenn man das so
weit nehmen kann praktisch salat toko
kann ja auch so mit zur arbeit nehmen
dann hat alles so richtig schön
funktioniert ja bin ich auch vor allem
kanada auch gern noch gelbe paprika mit
reinschmeißen hat man ob sie geld mit
drin weil ich so das farbspiel mit grün
und rot ganz schön finde vor allem auch
geschmacklich mit dem rucola ganz leicht
und ja das ist ein sommer salat den ich
sehr weiter empfehlen kann nicht staub
probieren nein
ok und für alle anderen dieses probieren
möchten ihr könnt gerne aufs tennis -
blog.de gehen da gibt's noch mal das
komplette red und ich freue mich wenn
ich wenigstens nach macht und einfach
nicht mal wieder einschaltet und im
rathaus leer also schmeckt